Telltale's The Walking Dead isn't the
first game to employ the episodic format
nor is it the first video game to have a
wonderfully engaging story but The
Walking Dead engages players in its
narrative in a unique way and telltale
has made interesting and deliberate game
design decisions in order to do so it
basically breaks down into decision
making a balance between scripted and
rewards and sequences as well as the
forging of an emotional connection
between the player and the characters
and circumstances they encounter in game
no spoilers I promise
obviously these three are inexorably
linked but let's try and break it down
first up we've got the main mechanic of
The Walking Dead which permeates
everything from dialogue options to
binary impulse decisions and that's
choice and consequence the
choose-your-own-adventure nature of The
Walking Dead certainly seems to appeal
to some people more than others the
series has even come under fire for
appearing to be more of a movie than a
game due to its focus on often showing
the play of the story rather than having
them directly control the action that
telltale deliberately fashion so
narrative around play a choice although
some decisions are more impactful than
others nearly everything you choose
makes a difference telltale has an
optional feature which tells the player
when they've said or done something that
another character is going to remember
take for example you siding with one
person over another in an argument both
characters will recall the choice you
made and that will inevitably have
repercussions down the track knowing
that your decisions no matter how
trivial have a perceivable effect on the
world and it's characters keeps you more
invested in the protagonist there's a
section where you have a limited amount
of feared to hand out to your companions
if you see the children their parents
will be happy but you have to ignore
some of the other survivors this has the
potential to breed resentment
who misses out on the solely needed
supplies your character's personality is
determined for your actions season
impact upon which characters have your
back when you need it it's important
that these decisions are always on a
timer on the one hand it's the game
reminding you that no one in real life
is going to wait five minutes for you to
continue a conversation but it's also a
reminder that despite how slow things
might be going dire situations are
always looming and inevitable and you
have to keep moving on and then the dire
stuff happens the walking dead hits you
with split second binary decision making
sometimes when you don't expect it
huge choices like deciding who to save
or sacrifice from the zombie driven
peril after learn at you to resolve in
six seconds and these choices often have
the largest consequences consequential
decision-making causes players to
inevitably feel much more responsible
and accountable for their actions no
matter how small and help you think
about how those actions might help hurt
or generally affect the characters who
might be making similar decisions
regarding you later on a hotly debated
feature of The Walking Dead is the
balance between scripted sequences and
branching paths there's been some
grumbling that while there is a lot of
decision-making in The Walking Dead none
of it is meaningful because even the
divergent paths tend towards similar or
sometimes the very same outcome while
the outcry is fair we have to remember
that the Walking Dead ultimately has a
very specific idea of where the plot is
going and where it ends in season 1 the
protagonist has one broad ultimate goal
so telltale isn't exactly going to let
you say screw this and kill yourself for
instance you're also often part of a
larger group so while you may be able to
sway individuals Swain group mentality
is an objectively difficult task in the
scenarios that you're in let's go back
to the idea of the inevitability a
zombie apocalypse brings with it
sometimes you get in a situation where
there's no time to decide and you just
have to keep moving The Walking Dead
knows this and some
keeps pushing you further forward even
if you don't necessarily want to so long
cutscenes happen they usually depict
trouble and QuickTime sequences another
common complaints only happen during
life or death scenarios meaning there's
usually only one way out and you'll be
kept on track at the same time the
interactive freedom you have during
quieter moments is vital to keep players
invested in the scripted sections
it's the unscripted moments which let
the player explore decide and ultimately
feel that they belong to the narrative
world and understand why the
circumstances within it are so important
to the characters people who play The
Walking Dead will experience a lot of
the same major plot points so yeah it's
linear in that sense but the journey to
those points and the circumstances
surrounding how everything happened will
always be unique lasts up and what is
really a culmination of everything else
is the way in which telltale ensures
that players have an emotional
connection to the characters and the
narratives there's a moment in season 2
of The Walking Dead where you finally
have the upper hand over an evil
character who spent all his time
manipulating and killing all the
characters I'm a pretty emotionally
driven person who still cries at the
beginning of Finding Nemo so it wasn't
totally out of character for me to be
dragged into the drama of it all but I
remember being surprised at how angry I
was the individual had murdered
innocence and brutally injured somebody
who I decided through the course of the
game was one of my protagonists closest
friends earlier in the story I'd chosen
to stand up to the villain and I was
defeated I tried and failed to reason
with him when he acted out and now I was
genuinely angry I realized that through
some combination of the way telltale had
crafted this character and the choices I
had personally made in an attempt to
reason with his cruel dictatorship that
I really really hated him I never found
myself hating a fictional character so
incredibly as I did this one and it's to
tell tales credit that they can so often
elicit strong emotional reactions like
mine The Walking Dead isn't everybody's
cup of tea and I get that but the way
they manage to tell the story they
wanted to tell while still making the
player feel like it was their own
feeling involved and personally
accountable is
SIV Telltale's walking-dead formula is
something new and despite its flaws it's
an important point for video games
storytelling let me know down in the
comments if you're a fan of The Walking
Dead or if there's another game you can
think of with an epic story as involved
as this one I'll be back next week with
more things to say to your faces
you